I want to tell you a story that never ends.
a looping story - this story is end to end
I am going to make subtitles for myself.
A long time ago, 108 green forest heroes gathered in the waters of Liangshan
Songjiang, their owner, said: "Please tell us a story."
The hero began to say: "A long time ago, 108 green forest heroes gathered in the waters of Liangshan"
The hero began to say: "A long time ago"
Like this, this story has been connected end to end.
Every computer scientist knows the difference between recursion and iteration
Recursion is a function layer to solve itself
And iteration is to repeat the same process but enter different variables
Child, I have to be a challenge because my Chinese is not very good.
I can hardly speak Chinese, but I want to try to tell this story in two languages.
I will use English and Chinese.
In addition, I don’t need such a round satin to tell a story.
I want to try if I can bring it with Mobius.
This is the version of Liangshan with Mobius
There may be many mistakes, I apologize in advance
This is a recursive story with no ending, but I will iterate in two languages.
If I speak five languages, then I will use five languages, but now I will try it in two languages.
A long time ago, 108 green forest heroes gathered in the waters of Liangshan
Songjiang, their owner, said: "Please tell us a story, use Chinese."
The hero begins to say
"A long time ago, the green forest heroes will gather in the Liangshan of the waters"
Their village leader Song Jiang commanded
Please give... please tell us a story.
The hero begins to say
use English
A long time ago, 108 green forest heroes gathered in the waters of Liangshan
This is a Mobius strip
You said, "A strange story."
However, all Chinese people know this famous story.
108 ancient green forests in ancient China, the uprising against the corrupt court
This "Water Margin" is about these wonderful people.
Wonderful uprising
Every character
Some chapters are about these people.
Children, you definitely don’t want to meet them on the street.
These people are holding an axe or a big knife one by one.
They are all insurgents
Under the leadership of the Songjiang River, the leader of the village, against the court
Song Jiang was also forced by the court to Liangshan
I am going back to my hot cocoa now.
I want to be a math fan
You should know the Drost effect
I think a person who understands mathematics, you should also know Droste hot cocoa.
On the box, a waitress holds a plate
On the plate is still a box of Drose hot cocoa, the image on the box is still her
This is a box of recursive images. In fact, the recursion in an advertisement like this is called the Drost effect.
I want to apologize to my native English audience for my bad Chinese.
My Chinese is not very good
Yeah, I forgot, I almost forgot Chinese.
Because 40 years ago, I studied Chinese.
Also teaches astronomy, at the Purple Mountain Observatory of Nanjing University.
In the south of China, Jiangsu Province
But now, I almost forgot how to speak Chinese, so I apologize again.
But every time I speak Chinese, I will still be very happy.
Come over, look at this!
Under my room
There is a small forklift that will ship the Klein bottle from the warehouse...
Pull this thing, um, please look carefully...